the extraordinary courage of Britain's
Holocaust Survivors including 94 year
old Eric Hirsch who is with us here
today this government will legislate to
build the Holocaust Memorial and
learning center next to Parliament so
the testimonies of survivors like Eric
will be heard at the heart of our
democracy by every generation to come Mr
Speaker this morning I had meetings with
ministerial colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house I
shall have further such meetings later
today
thank you Mr Speaker shockingly one in
Six Women in the UK have experienced
economic abuse this is not just about
money but they're restricting of access
to other resources like food housing or
work it's a lesser known aspect of
course of control affect my constituents
the prime minister's constituents and
every member across this house what
plans does the play Minister have to
review in detail government departments
and policies uh the way that government
departments and policies can be
exploited by abusers to ensure that
these loopholes can be closed Minister
well Mr Speaker The Honorable lady
raises an important point and let me
assure her that this government is
committed to tackling violence against
women and girls that's why we pass the
landmark domestic abuse Bill introduce
new offenses for example coercion
coercive control stalking and others and
will continue to do everything we can to
ensure women and girls feel as safe as
they deserve and rightly should be well
cool longitude
thank you Mr Speaker while I was
disappointed that Dudley did not make
the final cut in the latest leveling up
funding round
I am of course pleased that we received
the 25 million pounds towns deal
[Applause]
the brand new Duncan Edwards Leisure
facility and a transport interchange
project secured since my election in
2019.
[Applause]
but but our High Street Mr Speaker is on
its knees so will the Prime Minister
meet with me and Dudley Council to
discuss our leveling up bid and how we
can ensure success in the next round
well Mr Speaker my honorable friend is a
great advocate for his constituents
[Applause]
and I'm delighted that thanks to his
efforts Dudley has received 25 million
pounds from the towns fund I know there
will be disappointment about the
leveling up fund but all bids including
that made by Dudley Council can receive
feedback to strengthen their bid for
future rounds of funding and I would be
very happy to meet him further to
discuss
the leader of the opposition christama
thank you Mr Speaker this week we will
remember the Six Million Jews murdered
in the Holocaust and all those scarred
by genocide since as we Mark Holocaust
Memorial Day we must all commit across
this house to defeat Prejudice and
hatred wherever we may find it to work
for a better future we must find light
in the darkness could also join the
Prime Minister wishing everyone a happy
Burns night
Mr Speaker Zara Alina was walking home
from a night out with her friends when
she was savagely attacked assaulted and
beaten to death
Zara was a brilliant young woman a
trainee lawyer with a bright future
her killer is a violent racist
woman-hating Thug not fit to walk the
same streets
but that's precisely the problem
he was free to walk the same streets
the inspectorate report into her case
says that
opportunities were missed by the
probation service that could have
prevented this attack and saved her life
does the Prime Minister accept those
findings
Mr Speaker this was a truly terrible
crime
and as the Chief Inspector has found the
failings in this case and indeed others
were serious and indeed unacceptable
in both of the cases that are in the
public domain these these failures can
be traced to failings in the initial
risk assessment and that's why immediate
steps are being taken to address the
serious issues raised
okay estaba
I'm glad he accepts those findings
the report also says that Staffing
vacancies and excessive workloads
contributed to those fatal failures
and it makes absolutely clear this was
not a one-off
as the report says these are systemic
issues in the probation service
they're clearly ministerial
responsibilities does the Prime Minister
accept those findings as well
yeah prime minister Mr Speaker let me
outline for The Honorable gentleman
exactly what steps we are taking and
that's to include
and that's to ensure that mandatory
training is to improve risk assessments
is being put in place it's mandating
checks with the police and Children's
Services before a probation officer can
recommend to the court that a convicted
offender be given electronically
monitored offense and implementing new
processes to guarantee the Swift recall
of offenders and the action we are
taking is already making a difference as
for example we see in the reduction of
the number of electronically monitored
curfews being given by the courts
estaba
Mr Speaker it was barking dagenham and
havering that tragically and fatally let
Zara down
but across the country Probation
Services are failing after a botched
then reversed privatization after a
decade of under investment it's yet
another vital Public Service on its
knees after 13 years of Tory government
I spoke to Zara's family this morning
it's hard to convey to this house the
agony that they've been through
they say that the government has blood
on their hands over these failures
he's accepted the findings of the report
does he also accept what Zara's family
say
prime minister well Mr Speaker my heart
of course goes out to Zara's family he
mentioned accountability the Probation
Services has taken action where failings
have been found and where that has been
appropriate and with regard to the
overall service because of the extra
investment we're putting in there's now
155 million pounds a year it's being put
into the probation service so that we
can deliver better supervision of
offenders there's also been an increase
in the number of senior probation
officers but one of the other things we
must remember Mr Speaker if we do want
to increase the safety of women and
girls out on our streets that we need
tough sentencing and that's why this
government passed the police crime and
sentencing act which The Honorable
gentleman opposite and his party opposed
[Applause]
[Music]
in light of the case of Zara I really
don't think the Prime Minister should be
boasting about the protection that he's
putting in place for women and I'm not
going to take lectures from him about
that
does the Prime Minister agree
that any politician who seeks to avoid
the taxes they owe in this country is
not fit to be in charge of taxpayer
money
well Mr Speaker I'm pleased to make my
position on this matter completely clear
to the house
the issues the issues in question
occurred before I was prime minister
[Applause]
the appointment with regard to the
appointment of the minister without
portfolio the usual appointments process
was followed no issues no issues were
raised with me when he was appointed to
his current role and since I commented
on this matter last week more
information has come forward
and that is why I have asked the
independent advisor to look into the
matter now I obviously can't prejudge
the outcome of that but it is right but
it is right that we fully investigate
this matter and establish all the facts
[Music]
Mr Speaker
he avoided the question I think any
anybody watching would think it's fairly
obvious that someone who seeks to avoid
tax can't also be in charge of tax yeah
for some reason the Prime Minister can't
bring himself to say that or even
acknowledge the question now last week
the Prime Minister told this house that
the chair of the Tory party had
addressed his tax Affairs in full and
there was nothing to add
this week after days of public pressure
the Prime Minister now says there are
serious questions to answer
what changed
prime minister
I know I know he reads from these
prepared sheets but he should listen to
what I actually said
[Applause]
since I commented on this matter last
week more information including a
statement
including a statement by the minister
without portfolio has entered the public
domain which is why it's right that we
do establish the facts and
y could step back let me take a step
back now of course of course of course
the politically expedient thing to do
would be for me would be for me to have
said that this matter must have been
resolved by Wednesday at noon
but I believe in proper due process
foreign
that's why that's why I appointed an
independent advisor and that's why the
independent advisor is doing his job but
the opposition can't have it both ways
the shadow leader is also his party
chair both
urged me and the government to appoint
an independent adviser and now he
objects to that independent advisor
doing their job it
political opportunism and everyone can
see through it
foreign
we all know why the Prime Minister was
reluctant to ask his party chair
questions about family finances and tax
avoidance
but his
[Applause]
his failure
his failure to sack him when the whole
country could see what's going on shows
how hopelessly weak he is
a prime minister overseeing chaos
overwhelmed at every turn
he can't say when ambulances will get to
heart attack victims again he can't say
when the prison system will keep streets
safe again he can't even deal with tax
avoiders in his own cabinet
is he starting to wonder if this job is
just too big for him
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker the difference
between him and me is that I stand by my
values and my principles even when it is
difficult
when I disagree fundamentally with the
previous prime minister I resigned from
the government
he sat next to the member for Islington
North
when anti-Semitism ran right
when his predecessor sided with our
opponents that's what's weak Mr Speaker
he has no principles and just Petty
policy
thank you very much Mr Speaker
for our most vulnerable children school
is often their principal place of safety
as well as education but as reported in
my review of school exclusions for the
government in 2019 the unacceptable and
illegal use of off-rolling is still
shutting a worrying number of children
out of the classroom out of learning and
out of the protection they need from
gangs violence and domestic abuse and
whilst there has been some impressive
and excellent work done by the
Department of Education to address this
terrible practice what more can my right
humble friend do to ensure that we now
permanently exclude off-rolling from our
schools
Minister well my honorable friend raises
an important issue and the government is
clear that off-rolling is unlawful and
unacceptable in any form and the
department for Education continues to
work with ofsted to tackle it where
Olmsted finds it it will always be
addressed in the inspection report and
it could also lead to a school's
leadership being judged inadequate we
don't come to lead with the SMP students
Mr Speaker let me start by echoing the
sentiments of the Prime Minister and the
leader of the opposition in relation to
Holocaust Memorial Day truly horrific
crimes that we must never forget and
Endeavor to ensure are never repeated
may I also send my heartfelt thoughts
and indeed I hope those of all the costs
to the chamber to the firefighter who's
in serious condition in Edinburgh at
this moment in time following the blaze
in Edinburgh just a few days ago
Mr Speaker may I ask the Prime Minister
what advice would he have for
individuals seeking to protect their
personal finances should they seek out
our future chair of the BBC to help
secure an 800 000 pounds loan
should they set up a trust in Gibraltar
and hope that hmrc simply don't notice
or should they do as others have done
and simply apply for non-dom status
[Music]
prime minister
is that Mr Speaker Mr Speaker let me
share with the honorable gentleman
expressing my sympathies to the families
and indeed the firefighter who's
currently in hospital I'm sorry to hear
that and wish him a speedy recovery Mr
Speaker I'm proud of the record of this
government is supporting the most
vulnerable in our society just this
winter helping All Families 900 pounds
for their energy bills raising the
national living wage to record levels
and ensuring that our pensioners get the
support they need that's what this
government is doing to ensure Financial
Security in this country
I'm not sure what question is that the
Prime Minister thought I asked but that
certainly was not it Mr Speaker but
let's let's be clear about this this is
now a matter of the prime minister's own
integrity and accountability after all
when there was questions about the Home
Secretary the secretary and concerns
about horrible in relation to National
Security he chose tobacco now the chair
of the Tory party he's choosing to Back
Him despite a five million pound penalty
from hmrc and of course he's seeking to
protect the former prime minister
despite his cozy Financial relationship
with the chair of the BBC isn't it
Little Wonder the people in Scotland May
well just consider the Tory party to be
a parcel of Rogues
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker what I'm standing
up for is proper due process that's why
we have an independent advisor it's
right that the independent advisor
conducts his investigation that's how we
will ensure accountability and that's
what I would deliver Rob Roberts
thank you Mr Speaker Wales has almost 40
times more people than England waiting
more than two years for NHS treatment
despite having less than five percent of
the population sad case of devolve and
forget unfortunately which does a
disservice to my constituents in Delhi
could the Prime Minister confirm that
the UK government remains concerned
about the health care of the people in
Wales and given that the North Wales
Health Board has had it for eight years
could he come up with a way of putting
the Welsh labor government into special
measures prime minister well Mr Speaker
as The Honorable gentleman highlights
the NHS right across our Union is facing
pressure because of some of the
challenges of flu and covert in
particular causing High bed occupancy
this winter we are focused on delivering
on the people's priorities and bringing
down the backlog we've currently already
eliminated weights of over two years and
as The Honorable gentleman says there's
more to go that's why our investment
this week into mental health treatment
will ensure that we can ease the
pressure further and a e and I continue
to delivering that across the country so
Jeffrey Donaldson give Mr Speaker can I
Echo the comments of the Prime Minister
in relation to Holocaust Memorial Day
and as we think of the situation in
Ukraine we also extend our best wishes
to president zielinski on his birthday
today
[Music]
freedom of religion or belief is
important in this country
Isabel Von Spruce was praying silently
outside an abortion clinic in Birmingham
when she was arrested and questioned by
the police not about her written or
spoken words but about her thoughts
we value freedom of religion or belief
in this country
will the Prime Minister commit to
examine the laws of the United Kingdom
to ensure that this country remains a
beacon for freedom of religion or belief
across the world prime minister well uh
Mr Speaker of course
of course of course we believe in
Freedom of religious expression and
belief in this country but we also are
balancing that with the rights of women
to seek legal and safe abortions that is
currently being discussed in this
Parliament these matters are always
matters of free vote and I know members
will treat them with the sensitivity
that they deserve not to live fault
thank you Mr Speaker innocent civilians
are being murdered in Ukraine on Putin's
orders as we speak and as we speak in a
a a warmed House of Commons families are
freezing because their electricity is
being cut off by Russian forces Putin
believes that Ukraine is more important
to him than the Free World and is moving
to a full War footing so the ukrainians
must make gains on the battlefield and
the next six months are crucial they
need a full range of weapons Mr Speaker
Air Defense Artillery longer range
missiles and tanks and enough to make a
real difference the UK has shown great
leadership on the issue can I ask
therefore my right honorable friend to
use every means at his disposal domestic
and international to honor the courage
of the people of Ukraine and to defend
the whole world order because ultimately
that is what we're really talking about
prime minister well Mr Speaker I've made
clear that the UK and our allies must
accelerate our efforts to ensure Ukraine
wins this war and secures a lasting
peace last year the United Kingdom
provided 2.3 billion pounds in military
aid to Ukraine the largest package of
support of any European nation and we
will at least match that again this year
and as my right honorable friend knows
last week I announced that we would gift
many battle tanks as part of the next
major package of UK support to Ukraine
and I'm pleased that our friends and
allies are preparing to follow our lead
Mr Speaker London has it all Prime
Property shopping stalls even the
perfect time zone for money laundering
and while there has been movement with
Russian oligarchs it's not just them we
know that there are relatives of regimes
that we all condemn on both sides of
this house that are running bogus
Islamic centers just as France to stash
their dirty cash amongst other things so
when will the NCA be adequately financed
so we can be a world leader in
anti-corruption as we promised in 2016
or is there a lack of political will to
upset the apple carts well well Mr
Speaker The Honorable lady should know
that we're coloring the process of
legislating the economic crime bill
which which puts in place many more
measures to allow us to tackle some of
the issues that she raised and also
introduces the economic crime Levy which
will provide considerably more funding
to tackle economic crime in the UK some
McCartney thank you
thank you Mr Speaker the trans penine
rail upgrade is underway which is good
news
um with stations in slow it and Marsden
getting improvements but what's not such
good news Mr Speaker is the dozens of
daily rail service cancellations by
trans penine Express which is causing
absolute misery for my constituents
trying to get to work trying to get to
College trying to visit family and
friends the franchisees up in May Mr
Speaker so does the Prime Minister agree
with me enough is enough if transpan and
express don't get to grips with this we
need to strip them of the franchise and
get somebody in who will deliver the
reliable rail services for my
constituents
well Mr Speaker we have been clear that
the current service is simply not
acceptable rail North partnership is
working with a company on a service
improvement plan and my honorable friend
the rail minister is having weekly
meetings with them
what gentlemen points out transplant on
the express contract does expire in May
and whilst there are currently
discussions about that new contract if
ministers conclude that the operator
cannot be turned around then other
decisions may be made Olivia Blake
Mr Speaker from Rwanda to deaths in the
channel and the latest Scandal of
missing children refugees and
campaigners have today gathered outside
Parliament to highlight the impact of
the hostile environment on people in the
migration and Asylum system rather than
cruel gimmicks like Rwanda isn't the
best way of deterring Channel Crossing
Crossings saving lives and breaking the
business model of criminal gangs to
introduce safe and legal routes to claim
Asylum
well Mr Speaker this just is about
fairness it's about fairness for those
that seek to come here legally it's
about fairness for those who are here
and our ability to integrate and support
those who we want to what we will do is
in break the cycle of criminal gangs
which are causing Untold misery leading
to deaths in the channel and that's why
we will introduce legislation that makes
it clear that if you come here illegally
we will be able to detain you and
swiftly remove you to a safe third
country that is the reasonable and
Common Sense approach that the vast
majority of the British public supports
[Music]
the Prime Minister will be aware of my
concern that mental health patients
should not be forced into accidents and
emergency departments when what they
really need is Specialist Care can you
say more about the extra money that's
being made available for Urgent mental
health care
facilities and and also what impact he
thinks that'll have first on the
treatment of mental health patients but
also on the general situation in a e
departments Minister my um my runnable
friend is absolutely right people in
Mental Health crisis deserve
Compassionate Care in a safe and
appropriate setting and too often they
end up in a e when they should be
receiving specialist treatment elsewhere
this week's announcement is in mental
health ambulances crisis cafes crisis
houses and Mental Health Urgent
Treatment Centers will make sure that
patients do get the vital help they need
whilst easing pressures on emergency
departments and freeing up staff time my
honorable friend is absolutely right to
highlight this issue our announcement
this week will make a major difference
your lips today
as a trustee of the Holocaust Memorial
Day trust this week I was honored to
hear from Leah lesser of Holocaust
Survivor who came to this country by
herself at the age of eight because her
parents believe that the UK was a safe
haven for vulnerable children this week
I also read the government's own
statistics which said that there are 200
Asylum seeking unaccompanied children
who are missing from hotels in the UK
ministers have admitted that they have
no idea about the whereabouts of these
children so could I asked the Prime
Minister does he still think that the UK
is a safe haven for vulnerable children
Mr Speaker the United Kingdom has opened
up its hearts and homes to hundreds of
thousands of people over the last few
years from Syria from Afghanistan from
Ukraine from Hong Kong and provided
refuge and Sanctuary to many children in
that process but the reports that we
have read about are concerning local
authorities have a statutory duty to
protect all children regardless of where
they go missing from and in that
situation they work closely with the
local agencies including the police to
establish their whereabouts and that's
why it's so important that we end the
use of hotels for under some accompanied
Asylum Seekers and reduce pressure on
the overall system that's what our plans
will do James dodridge hey Mr Speaker
constituents in south end and Rochford
very much welcome the energy bill
support scheme that's helped 99 of
households around the United Kingdom
with Rising fuel prices despite Putin's
barbaric war in Ukraine can the Prime
Minister assure my constituents that
indeed this house that he's committed to
continue helping with the cost of living
not only this winter but next winter
yeah
my uh my honorable friend is absolutely
right about this government's commitment
to support all families with the cost of
living this winter around 900 pounds of
support but next year as the energy
price guarantee evolves it will still be
there to support families with around
500 pounds of support and this comes on
top of record increases in the National
living wage worth about sixteen hundred
pounds and supporting our pensioners in
the most vulnerable by inflating Fair
benefits and pensions with inflation
live effort
in 2021 the government enabled you have
joining precaution former Chef to Putin
and founder of Wagner to dodge UK
sanctions to pursue a case in London
against British journalists Elliot
Higgins who had exposed pagosians link
to Wagner
but it goes in believe that silencing
Higgins would get his sanctions lifted
the overriding of UK sanctions was
approved by the treasury when the Prime
Minister was Chancellor
fragosian's English lawyers wrote that
serving notice on Higgins and I quote
will require treasury approval
so what values did the Prime Minister
apply when he allowed a Putin warlord to
use our courts to try to silence a
British journalist and undermine UK
sanctions
well Mr Speaker I'm proud of our record
in leading actually when it comes to
sanctioning those people connected with
the Putin regime I think at last time we
sanctioned over a thousand people in
Frozen tens of billions of pounds of
assets I am aware of the cases raised we
are looking at it but there is as he
knows ofsi who deal with the licensing
situations in these matters but I'm
happy to get back to him on the specific
case that he raised Little Richard
Memorial Day and welcome his renewed
commitment today regarding the Holocaust
Memorial and learning center will the
Prime Minister join me in encouraging
members from across the house to sign
the Holocaust Education trust book of
commitment which will be in Parliament
today and tomorrow pleasure to remember
the Holocaust fight anti-Semitism and
support the important work of the
Holocaust educational trust prime
minister I thank my honorable friend and
as I said earlier we will legislate to
help build the Holocaust Memorial Land
Learning Center next to Parliament to
serve as a powerful reminder of the
Holocaust its victims and where
Prejudice can lead if unchallenged I
also join her in thanking the Holocaust
educational trust for their fantastic
work and I join honorable friend in
encouraging all members to sign the book
of commitment as I will be doing later
today and this Slaughter thank you Mr
Speaker a week ago my constituent
alireza akbari was executed by order of
the regime in Iran in the three years
proceed the days following his murder
the UK government made little effort to
protect the life or protest the death of
a British national tomorrow Mr akbari's
family and I meet the foreign office
minister they want to hear what helped
the government could offer them at this
time of their greatest suffering today
this house wants to hear from the Prime
Minister what sanction he will impose on
the regime beyond the trifling steps
taken so far first and foremost but he
shows some courage follow the lead of
the United States from the European
Parliament and prescribe the entire
revolutionary guard Corps as a terrorist
organization prime minister
Mr Speaker the regime is prolonging the
suffering of the family and it is sadly
typical of their disregard for basic
human dignity I've spoken before about
my views in Iran when I was before the
liaison committee and Iran must now
provide answers about the circumstances
of his death and his burial we have have
actually pressed the Iranian regime
formally through their charged Affairs
in London and the foreign Ministry in
Tehran and will continue to do so until
the family get the answers they deserve
and have sanctioned several members
connected with the case
speaker can I thank the Prime Minister
and the chancellor for visiting Hampden
hasland and just last week to hear about
the transformative difference the
leveling up funding will make this is a
historic investment with over 40 million
pounds secured so does he agree with me
that we're delivering it on exactly what
was promised in 2019 to the areas that
were forgotten the most black Hamburg
and has London and will he visit once
works are completed to see the
difference himself well my honorable
friend is a fantastic Champion for her
local community and the result showed
when the chancellor and I were lucky to
visit her last week and as she pointed
out and as did many of the people that
we spoke to this was an area they've
been had had been forgotten neglected
for decades but it's this government
that is putting in the investment
spreading opportunity making jobs and
making sure that people can feel
enormously Pride of the place that they
call home
Mr Speaker does the Prime Minister
realize that most people in my
constituency think it's his role to keep
our country safe
is he aware that in all those years I've
been in Parliament I have never heard a
situation where our army and armed
forces are so run down that the chairman
of the defense select committee and the
secretary say for defense both say our
Armed Force has been hollowed out and
were unfit to put a division into active
service what's he gonna do about that
Minister Mr Mr Speaker The Honorable
judgment seems to forget the fact that
we've invested an extra 24 billion
pounds in our armed for services it's a
record uplift in defense spending
ensures that we are one of the leading
Spenders on defense in NATO and we will
continue to ensure that we have one of
the best equipped fighting forces
anywhere in the world and as we can see
by the recent announcement on tanks we
continue to lead the world when it comes
to standing up for not just our safety
but the safety of our allies around the
world so Michael Penning thank you very
much Mr Speaker and as of and as a
former Prime I thought a whole house
will pray for the firefighter that's
fine for his life in Scotland today our
Emergency Services go one way into the
danger while we come the other way and
our thoughts of prayer should be with
them on a separate note prime minister
the coronborough council the
conservative leg Council in my
constituency have done a fantastic job
in building new houses social housing
and Council houses can the Prime
Minister assure me that we're not going
to be pushed into Greenbelt anymore than
we have already and we can protect the
children's in my constituency yeah prime
minister well Mr Speaker The Honorable
gentleman and I join him in praising his
local Council for ensuring that we build
homes in the right places and make sure
that our young people can fulfill the
dream of home ownership but he's also
right to say that this government will
always protect our precious green spaces
and the recent changes to our planning
reforms will ensure that we can protect
the green belt everywhere and his local
community and others will benefit from
those protections as we keep our local
areas beautiful our 10 day
thank you Mr Speaker UK in a changing
Europe has reported that at the end of
2022 60 of Voters said their cost of
living had increased and 38 that their
personal finances had been negatively
affected from not being a member of the
European Union well Obi forecasts a four
percent reduction in GDP only two-fifths
of which have already happened surely
the Prime Minister would agree with me
with the electorate and the experts that
brexit has only served to exacerbate
cost of living and economic challenging
facing these islands
Mr Speaker
Russia's illegal war in Ukraine and the
impact has had on energy supplies has
nothing to do with brexit Mr Speaker but
what we are doing is ensuring that we
can support families with those cost of
living pressures that's why we provided
900 pounds of support this winter with
energy bills that's why we're increasing
the national living wage to record
levels and we will continue to stand
behind Britain's families until we can
bring inflation back down to where it
belongs Virginia across
Mr Speaker I know the Prime Minister
will share my concerns
even 130
may lose their jobs at the Two Sisters
chicken factory in clangovney one of the
largest employers on honest mourn what
support can the government offer to both
my constituents who are affected by this
devastating news and their wider
community at this difficult time
Mr Speaker I'm very sorry to hear about
the job losses that The Honorable lady
raises my thoughts are with those
affected and their families I know how
distressing that will be for them and
I'm pleased to say that DWP has
procedures in place to support
communities when situations like this
arise and we will work very closely with
her to do what we are doing everywhere
across the country and that's provide
good well-paid jobs for everyone because
that is the best way to build a happy
and secure Life currently in Paris thank
you Mr Speaker exercise is essential for
both physical and mental well-being but
with spiral energy costs many venues
like the freedom Leisure centers in my
constituency are struggling to call
while some sectors will receive extra
support the support and Leisure industry
will not if the Prime Minister agrees
with me that this sector is vital to the
long-term health of our communities why
is his government not providing them
with a financial support they need to
thrive
prime minister well Mr Speaker of course
I agree with honorable lady that
exercise and legislances are important
and that's why we provided significant
support to them during covid and Beyond
and with regard to Energy prices now the
chancellor has set out the new relief
scheme that will run after the current
one expires it provides considerable
support to all sorts of organizations up
and down the country and I'm sure it
would benefit many businesses and
organizations in her constituency I
understand that the case referred to by
the right honorable member for Lurgan
Valley is currently before the courts it
is therefore covered by The house's
subjudice resolution and should not be
referred to in this house it is of
course open to any member to ask iWave
the resolution in particular case but
that that has not happened in this case
and so therefore should not be discussed
at all I will leave it at that
right
send his PM Jews before that caused the
Urgent question